Cheers, baby.
Here's to St. Barts.
The O.G. bitches are back.
I'm wondering if there's going
to be some cute guys there.
Oh, there's always somebody
to f***.
We need a new pirate.
Alright.
St. Barts, hello.
We made it!
Hi, I just got here
fresh from New York.
We're going back
to the same villa.
Is it bringing back memories?
We're all starving
and we don't want to eat
without you, and it's 4 o’clock!
Didn't you miss her?
(laughter)
You have a boyfriend?
You have no boyfriend?
I have whatever I want,
and I'm very pleased.
Will you tell us who it is?
(laughter)
I'm so normal
and even tempered.
Kelly is like dealing with
one of those Rubik Cubes.
I am an action verb.
You're an action verb?
Okay.
You can have me all day long!
You get a match and now the
house is on fire.
Names will never hurt me.
There's six women here,
and you're all divorced!
Kristen’s husband
was cheating.
He admitted to being a
member of the
affairs website.
Is it a flirting thing?
I know my truth.
Eagles don't fly
with pigeons, okay?
So go get your bread
crumbs and get back to me
tomorrow.
I'm trying with you!
I'm so trying with you!
I know, but you're not the right
girl for the right job, Kristen!
I need nurturing from Dorinda.
Is that a turtle? Look it!
Turtle time, baby.
Turtle time!
Yesss!
You think I already...
Oh, god.
Snatch guard!
We found out that Sonja
has a pretty kitty.
Boobs in the breeze!
We have ten guys showing up.
Ten guys, woo!
It's certainly not the first
hot dog I've seen on this trip,
but it's the first one I'm gonna
get on and ride.
Oh, gross!
I'm on it.
I don't know what an
Eddie Monster shoe looks like.
The pirate just tried to call me
nine thousand times.
Oh, look it.
I am your pirate.
That's the pirate?
Are you as horny as I am?
You need to go on a spiritual
retreat after this.
First, maybe I will go to a
mental house.
Mental hospital?
Yes.
Turn it off.
I love a powerful showerhead.
Woo! Uh oh.